the marketing campaign for the final
season of Game of Thrones is called for
the throne after seven seasons of
conflict betrayal and death who will win
the Iron Throne and rule Westeros in the
end
Daenerys says she was born to rule
Westeros she's a Targaryen the family
that made the iron throne and ruled for
300 years
Daenerys spends seasons in the Dothraki
sea and marine learning how to be a
queen and in season seven she invades
Westeros with her dragons and her army
Donny's whole story has been leading up
to her taking the throne so it almost
seems too obvious for her to win the big
question in Daenerys a story is what
kind of Queen is she does she burn all
her enemies or make peace
is she a tyrant like a father or will
she make the world a better place
maybe Daenerys will prove herself a
worthy queen by not taking the throne
because in season two Dany has a vision
where she reaches for the throne but
then turns away and goes beyond the wall
just like in season seven when she
chooses not to attack the capital and
instead goes beyond the wall to fight
White Walkers
Daenerys realizes that saving the world
is more important than her war for the
throne but saving the world might cost
Daenerys her life according to legend
the White Walkers were defeated before
by a warrior who sacrificed his beloved
wife it might be that Jon Snow is this
warrior and that his love Daenerys will
die Daenerys could finally prove herself
a worthy Queen by giving up the throne
and dying to save the realm but if
Daenerys dies he'll take the throne in
her vision Daenerys sees snow on the
throne so maybe John Snow will sit the
throne we learned in season seven that
John is the rightful heir to the throne
because he's the son of Prince Rhaegar
Targaryen John might not want to be king
of Westeros he didn't want to be king in
the north
but he'd likely accept the throne if he
saw it as his duty
John becoming King would be a kind of a
fantasy cliche a hero with the magic
sword defeating
the Dark Lord and ruling the realm will
Game of Thrones follow this trope there
are lots of hints in the books that John
will be king but this could mean a
darker colder kind of King there are
legends that humans once cooperated with
White Walkers and even married them
maybe John will make peace with the
White Walkers by becoming their new
knight King maybe by marrying one it
would be like how John makes peace with
the wildlings after loving Ygritte
there's all sorts of weird stuff in the
law about pacts and Stark Blood and
zombie men so some kind of dark
self-sacrifice might be John's fate if
John does become a night king or
something and Daenerys dies maybe their
child who will survive there are lots of
hints in season 7 about Daenerys and
John having kids so maybe their child
will sit the throne a son of Ice and
Fire
so those are the obvious options either
Daenerys or John or their child on the
throne with some kind of tragic magic
sacrifice but there are other
possibilities Gendry is the bastard son
of King Robert Baratheon bastards can't
inherit a throne unless they're
legitimized like Ramsay Bolton was if
Kendra was legitimized he would be
Robert's heir and arguably the rightful
king this bastard boy from flea bottom
could claim the throne of his father
begin dree is a minor character he's not
a political player he's a blacksmith and
he doesn't seem to want the throne at
most he might rule the Stormlands the
home of house Baratheon but he isn't a
very likely king in season 1 Sansa Stark
wants to be queen she hopes to marry
Prince Joffrey and that doesn't work out
but she spends the next six seasons
learning politics from some of the most
devious players of the game like Cersei
Elena and Littlefinger by season 7 Sansa
is a leader herself she rules Winterfell
with the support of the north and the
Vale after being used and abused for so
long Sansa clearly likes to be in charge
at its hinted that Sansa wants even more
power Sansa has no law
will claim to the Iron Throne that maybe
she could Littlefinger away in by murder
or marriage there are hints in the books
that Sansa might marry John or young
Griff it's the whole thing but the
season 7 finale and Sophie Turner's new
tattoo made clear that Sansa is loyal to
the Starks her home is Winterfell
so Sansa could end up clean in the north
but the Iron Throne at least in a show
seems less likely for Sansa Cersei
Lannister now has the throne but she
probably weren't lost
she can't be Daenerys and her dragons
and John and the White Walkers and the
witch Maggy the Frog prophesied that
Cersei will be cast down
Cersei says that she'd rather die than
surrender as in Blackwater when she
almost committed suicide Circe's on a
path of self-destruction and one theory
is that she'll try to use wildfire again
so she may be killed by her brother
lover Jaime
watch out Jaime and Cersei videos for
more but basically Jaime may kill the
Mad Queen Cersei just like he killed the
Mad King Aerys years ago after Jaime
killed Aerys he briefly sat the Iron
Throne so maybe he'll do the same after
killing Cersei the Kingslayer and clean
Slayer could be king if only for a
moment
cuz Jaime might not long outlive Cersei
he says he wants to die in her arms
it'll be cool if Tyrion was king the
despised exiled dwarf on the highest
seat in the land Varys did say that a
small man can cast a large shadow
but Tyrion doesn't want to be king eeep
says he wants to start a vineyard and
the people of Westeros don't want Tyrion
they hate him as a kin Slayer the
murderous imp who supposedly killed
Joffrey Tyrians more suited as an
advisor he could be hand of the king or
of the queen or a regent for Danny's
child or something maybe he'll rule the
Lannister castle Casterly Rock
but Tyrion as king seems unlikely
maybe Thrones will go full grimdark and
the White Walkers will win all the
characters we love will die and become
zombies and the night king will
said a cold throne Game of Thrones is a
brutal story but there is always some
hope amidst the darkness that's why the
characters keep fighting in an interview
author George Martin was asked if his
series will end in some horrible
apocalypse and Martin said no he says
the end will be bittersweet like the end
of The Lord of the Rings where the good
guys win but heroes like Frodo are
damaged and there are still problems
like the scouring of the shire Martin
says that's the kind of tone he wants
for the end of Thrones a bittersweet
victory
so the walkers won't win the throne but
there could be a different kind of twist
part of the point of Game of Thrones is
to show the problems with the power
structure that the throne represents
because the Throne puts madmen and
drunkards and psychos in charge of the
country it reduces women into pawns to
be traded for titles it causes Wars of
succession that burned the realm and
hurt the people and it distracts from
the real threat of the White Walkers in
the face of apocalypse the throne that
everyone's fighting for doesn't matter
there are hints that the throne will be
destroyed in Daenerys a--'s vision and
in this world book art we see the throne
room burned by a dragon fire or wildfire
maybe the throne will be broken and the
monarchy will end Westeros could split
into Seven Kingdoms again or try new
forms of government like Tyrion suggests
Daenerys lets marine choose their own
leaders may be breaking the wheel could
mean some kind of democracy the end of
the Iron Throne would bring uncertainty
and loss but it would also bring hope
for the future a bittersweet victory and
a dream of spring a comment below who
you think will win the Iron Throne if
you want to learn more about the history
and law and the meaning of Game of
Thrones you go to check out the books as
well as the main series there at the
dunk and egg prequels the World Book and
the new fire and blood history book you
can get any of these for free today by
signing up for a trial at audible.com
slash ASX members get a book each month
and if you cancel you keep the books so
next time you're driving or the gym you
can prepare for the final season of Game
of Thrones thanks for watching and
thanks to the patrons including ray
ohmic doodle Mel of shock Alice growl
Michelle Brown Kevin Olsen a and J
Robinson go hard Ackerman Peter Alex
Tricia Hopkins Christopher Mason and max
pay Cheers
you